[Music]
you
hello in this class we'll be looking at
another cooperative variable another
gullible factor which is attention now
attention is a very interesting
cognitive factor because it signifies
the mental concentration the mental
effort somebody puts it to and so
attention is important why because
attention decides whether perception
takes place or not so even before
something is perceived even before
something is registered by the brain and
analyzed attention decides what message
is to be analyzed what stimuli is to be
analyzed and what stimuli is not to be
analyzed
now why is attention really necessary
think of a scenario where you could hear
a lot of things you could hear almost
all the stimuli which are impinging on
to you at any government movement it
would be very difficult to process all
the stimuli at any if every stimuli is
being imprinting on you you are able to
hear everything and so focusing or
concentration will be difficult and that
is why the cognitive system or our human
brain has the system of attention so
attention is just like a sieve or a
filter which separates those information
which needs to be processed in those
information which need not be process
and so basically then the question comes
in that how is attention directed so in
this particular lecture we will look
into attention we look into what are the
factors which control attention how is
intention manipulated and whether this
attention that we are talking about
whether this could be improved
so does attention span improve we'll
also look at some of the theories of
attention and talk about something
called automatic T of attention in
addition to it we'll also look at
something called the psychological
reflector
period which is basically a carrot which
is basically out process of attention so
let us then begin our section or
detention think of a scenario a car
driving scenario look at the picture on
the screen now when an expert driver car
drives a car he doesn't need to pay
attention to a lot of variable to a lot
of things he is an expert and so driving
is kind of a by-product to him and so he
doesn't not need to focus on all the
systems which are there in the car like
the gear the steering and so many other
things so what he could do an expert
could do is not only drive the car but
also start a conversation follow a
conversation fiddle with some gadgets
take up a phone call and do several
other things but reverse the scenario or
look at look at the scenario in the
picture in the picture you can see a no
wise driving a car remember the first
time you started driving a car or a
vehicle now at that point of time you
didn't know what the controls were and
you didn't knew so many other things
about the car or about the vehicle that
you were drawing or any new thing that
you learn and so you have to put your
attention or your mental consideration
into it because this meant will consider
concentration decides how you should be
doing a particular job into incase of
the car the no vice user pays attention
to whatever is happening around him
learns about the control learns about
how to move the vehicle and later on
when he practices for some time when he
has enough practice for some time he can
then use something called divided
attention where he doesn't need to focus
all his mental effort onto the controls
in car and with the driving can do other
jobs as well so basically attention is a
mental effort kind of a cognitive
resource which makes you focus on two
things remember in earlier classes in
smaller classes our teachers is to say
pay attention and the Kabat here was
that no matter how hard we paid
attention it used to jump
one object to another even if I ask you
right now to pay attention to something
or some object what would happen is that
for a few seconds you would be able to
focus your attention onto that thing and
it jumps on which basically means that
attention is very fiddly it keeps on
jumping from one thing to another and
that is why we have something called an
attention span which basically defines
the amount of time for which a
particular stimulus can be attended to
so then what is basically attention
attention basically requires the study
of cognitive resources and the
limitations of the cognitive system so
basically those cognitive psychologists
who are studying attention actually look
at what are the cognitive resources how
are the cognitive resources channelize
into making a cognitive decision making
a cognitive act like perception memory
and what are the limitations of this
this attention this filter that we are
talking about so attention is some time
also synonymously are related or
synonymously considered equivalent to
mental concentration now attention is
something which is very prominent
without attention it would be really
difficult and so as I said as you do
more and more practice what you could do
is you could take the attention that you
have the amount of attention that is
your cognitive resources that is
available to you and put it into other
jobs which means that people can
simultaneously then do what any other
job so one basic fact to know here is
that with practice attention span or
attention can be diverted you could use
your attention for doing multiple jobs
that is the question which I have here
and that says that thus people's
concentration change with practice the
question is does people's attention
actually go ahead and change with
practice with doing are we doing the job
over and over again all learning the job
over and over again
now one of the first person to talk
about attention was William James when
he said that attention cannot be focused
on one on more than one stimuli he he
predicted that attention can be only
paid on our attention can be studied for
only one stimuli but if we are die
working or if we are playing around with
many stimuli if we are focusing
ourselves or we if we are able to do a
number of jobs at the same time it is
not attention that we are studying it is
happiness that we are studying and so
this first definitions are these first
Clues basically give us something about
or tell us something about Artemis City
which is another outgrowth of attention
so as you become more practiced as you
have more practice you do not need a lot
of attention on to jobs and so most of
the jobs then become automatic think
about any morning any unusual morning
which is there and so when you get up
you go to doing your brushing and there
are several other things but if I ask
you this question do you remember doing
any of these or do you pay attention to
any of these jobs very seriously and
your answer would be no the reason being
that these are so routine jobs that
there is a process of doing it and so
what you tend to do when after you get
up is pay less and less attention to it
and the process itself becomes automatic
till the point of time when you either
miss a toothpaste or there is a one
element from the whole routine that is
not existing and if that happens your
attention is focused back on to the
situation and solving a problem with the
situation so the study of attention is
also important because at any given
point of time we have limited cognitive
resources the brain has limited
cognitive resources and these cognitive
resources have to be diverted is to be
used in a number of jobs that we have to
do and so we have to use it wisely and
that is my attention came comes into
play where it allocates very tells in
allocating these mental concentration
into
getting more eminent or more important
jobs done and making those jobs which
are routine as more automatic and more
sequential in nature now the question is
how do we study attention a problem is
how do we study attention
and a more relevant question here is
that can attention be paid to multiple
stimuli
let's deal with the first question how
do we study attention the moment you say
somebody the moment you ask somebody not
to pay attention on to something his
attention goes back into that particular
job and so it's really difficult to
study attention because if you ask
someone the only way I see of studying
attention is taking two groups one group
which is paying attention and the other
group which is not paying attention but
as soon as you release this instruction
as an experimental psychologist I would
say that as soon as you give this
instruction to people not to pay
attention there goes it
he starts paying attention back to
whatever job you are not asked him to
pay attention and that is because humans
means a curious they will do what they
are not asked to do so how do we study
attention the only way to study is to
have two groups in which one group
doesn't pay attention and so a noble
design was used to study attention we'll
talk about this design in a moment but
before that let's look at this question
of can we pay attention to two things at
the same time there are several answers
to it and several theories will discuss
into it think of a class a class which
is filled with a number of students who
was actually listening to a professor
who's professing at any point of time
there are so many stimuli which is being
imprisoned on your sense organs you have
a number of stimuli interactions a
number of stimuli which is trying to
capture its attention
but what you tend to do is focus
yourself on to the lecture and this
particular thing or this particular job
of focusing your attention on to one
particular thing is what is called
selective attention so selective
attention basically is selective
attention is basically using the filter
to focus on one job and to eliminate
other job to eliminate putting your
focus on two other jobs so as soon as
the teacher stops teaching you will soon
start hearing your class wrestling
against yourself your skin you can hear
the noise that the person who's sitting
right next to you is making you can hear
the fan the noise of the fan which was
there well amazingly when you were
actually looking at the professor when
he is teaching you actually didn't pay
any attention to all the other songs
which were there and this particular
thing this interesting thing of focusing
our attention on to one particular job
or one particular event is called
selective attention and so what we'll be
looking at now is something called
selective attention but even before
looking at selective attention let the
question is how do we study attention
and so a very ingenious design was used
to do that and that design uses
something called the the dichotic
listening task so as I said selective
attention is the term which refers to
the fact that we usually focus out
attention on too few tasks and events
rather than many of this particular task
and help assure one of the famous
figures in attention research states
that attention is basically equivalent
to any given movements people's
awareness and it encompasses it
comprises of only a tiny proportion of
the stimuli which he is receiving from
the environment now let's do a very
quick thing a very quick study to find
out how selective attention really works
and so on the display in front of you
you see two rows of animals now what he
earlier has happened is most of the
figures that you see are actually a
combination of a dog and a cat and there
are
some pure figures when I say pure
figures you what I really mean is a pure
dog and a pure cat take some time and do
tell me or you do do this exercise of
finding out which is the cat pure cat
and which is the pure dog now once you
are given this job you will soon realize
the only pure dog is this and the only
pure cat is this now how did you come up
with this answer for finding out this
answer what you really needed to do is
to scan each of these image one by one
and for that what you needed to do is to
focus all your attention or mental
concentration focus yourself into this
image and basically compare the
prototype as we saw in the perceptions
section prototype is basically the most
abstract abstraction that you have the
most clear abstraction that you have of
any category use that prototype to
compare each of this image with a pure
dog image in a pure cat image and once
you do that you'll realize that the
fifth image from the left on the top row
is the dog of your dog and similarly the
third image from the left bottom on on
the bottom row is a pure cat and what
you did right now when you did this job
of finding the pure cat in pure dog is
something called selective attention so
the idea here was how do we go ahead and
study attention and as I mentioned a few
minutes before the oil the best way to
do that is using something called
dichotic listening task now what is this
task art all about
so this dichotic task listening task
involves a listener a person who listens
through a headphone another on the
cavity or the hidden part here is that
both the heads or both the channels or
both the ears that this person has will
be receiving two different inputs so one
year will be seeing a different input
and the other year will be receiving a
different input when I mean input what
it really means is that they will be
receiving two different messages so it's
a situation like this where you can see
the one-year is receiving stimulus is
like God googy kind of thing and the
other here is using stimulus like Barbie
something like that so basically for the
people who take part in the dichotic
listening task are given a earphone and
the two years then receive different
messages now there are some obviously
there are some assumptions here or there
are some clues there are some points to
be noted here instructions that is
followed the first thing is that the
people have to shadow one here now what
does shadowing actually really mean the
shadowing means to repeat aloud whatever
you're hearing in a particular year that
the experimenter is asking you to do so
in the dichotic listening task what you
really have to do is both the years that
that you have received two different
inputs from two different microphones
turn to two different headphones and all
you have to do is to shadow one ear now
shadowing is repeating aloud whatever is
here on one other year so if it is right
here that you're shadowing whatever is
coming to your right ear you're going to
repeat that aloud now the rate of
presentation of stimuli in in a dichotic
listening task is very fast it is nearly
150 words per minute at the end of the
task people are asked to reveal what
information that they have gathered from
the message from both the years or from
a single ear and so the deal here is
that this experiment or this dichotic
listening task was designed by someone
called cherry in the year 1953 in a
classic study cherry define this
dichotic listening task now the question
was there are two different years on one
year you are doing shadowing the other
year you are not doing
during the question is whether you are
able to hear words from the year that
you are not shadowing which means that
whether you are able to hear from the
ear that you are not paying attention to
the answer to this cherry god was that
yes most people were able to hear some
information some messages or some kind
of stimulus property from the other year
and this information was basically two
words are two words stimulus properties
like what is the what is the message
type whether it is noise or whether it
is words which has been repeated or who
is speaking whether it is a female or a
male who's speaking
whether it is the message is in a
correct order which is a forward order
or whether the messages are in reverse
order this kind of information
basic stimulus information you can
gather from the non in intended or non
attended year but from the right hear
you you tend to hear everything so
basically this question here or this
property here tells us that people are
able to hear some kind of information
from the other year so basically
attending to one stimulus doesn't mean
that the information from the other year
will not come in or will not be attended
to so basic information or basic facts
from the other year is also attended to
like stimulus properties related to
basic message properties that is what is
attended to and so when a chairing later
this this particular thing he he said
that the unintended year or he found out
that his subjects from the unintended
year although could not analyze the
message the meaning of the message from
the unintended year but they could tell
the voice of the person who was
repeating it the kind of message that it
was whether it was noise white noise
which has been presented or it was words
and letters that was being repeated and
for another backward direction now what
they couldn't tell of the message which
was being played and the nun intended
year was whether what was the language
in interest it was being played and what
was the content of the message and so
this was the first demonstration or this
is the kind of a first demonstration a
very ingenious design to study attention
now as I related before studying
attention is difficult because as you
say don't pay attention to this people
start paying attention and so this
design has been used in a lot of
cognitive psychology tasks or a lot of
experimental tasks which measure
attention so the question here is what
kind of information do we get from the
intent on intended or the unattended
here and and whether some information
and the meaning level can also bypass
the attentional filter the question to
be looked at is whether attention is it
is an all-or-none kind of a filter which
means that when you're not when you are
not focusing yourself or when you are
not using attentional filters whether
the one the messages which are not being
attended to whether they also pass and
at what level what kind of level do they
pass no cherries experiment very clearly
says that some information or some idea
about the non intended message you can
hear but then to what level is what
several other theories will argue and so
there are theories of attention which
has been put forward which go ahead and
actually talk about what is being
attended to and what are the matters
being attended to and what part of the
non attended message or what is it from
the non-degenerate message that people
can actually hear remember in this case
in this whole scenario we are talking
about focusing our attention on to one
year and we are attending and shadowing
it so when you're shadowing it it
becomes really difficult job because
shadowing requires you to you to repeat
aloud whatever is being said and so puts
a lot of mental effort on to the working
memory and so it will be very difficult
to actually go ahead and process
anything from their nan in a tendon here
so the question whether things from the
nan attended hear stimuli from the nan
engineer also moves back or are also
heard another paradigm that we'll go
into further is whether attention is
fixed or does it fluctuate and so one of
the reason that has been given in one of
the theories is that attention is never
100% and so it keeps on fluctuated
fluctuating from one ear to the other
year and that may be the reason why we
are able to hear from the other year but
we'll look at these debates one by one
when we move into it so let's start with
the first theory of attention which is
called the filter theory of attention so
let's start with the filter theory so
what does this theory actually say it's
a very simple theory which was proposed
by someone called Broadbent in the year
1958 and he proposed that there are
limits the cognitive limits of how much
information a person can attend to now
if the information available at at any
given time exceeds the capacity of the
mental the mental limit what will happen
is a filter is designed which will block
most information and let let things pass
or let those stimuli pass on to which we
are paying our attention and so it's a
in a simple demonstration I had tried to
look at the or tell you about this
theory or the filter theory now another
question is on what properties does the
filter work what is the variable switch
control the filter so let's first look
at what happens here so there are a
number of messages 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 these
are seven messages which are here and
which are impinging on to our cognitive
system and this is any cognitive barrier
which is there this is the barrier the
psychological and physical barrier which
I was talking about and as I said in in
previous lectures that the most
important thing in psychology is to
define how physical stimulus has entered
the psychological domain so this is the
barrier which is there it could be here
it could be I it could be anything
and so the number of messages which I am
painting on to it but the amount of
mental concentration the limitation the
limit is very less the mental
concentration available is very less and
so what happens a filter a quilter like
this is available which basically takes
in one message and lets it pass and
filters all this message away now the
question is on what properties does the
filter well and so the answer to this
has been given in terms of physical
properties of the stimulus is what so
physical properties of the stimuli guide
the filter so the filter the use of the
filter or the variables which control
filter is the physical property for
example the basic acoustics in the DLT
that decides whether you attend to it or
not and these basic caustics could be
location pitch loudness and so on and so
forth so then the filter theory goes
ahead and says then that any message
which you're not paying attention to
will be blocked
only those message which have not been
put to a limitation - will only get
passed on and this is the message which
you require and then the filter which
which filters out these messages is
based on something called the physical
property of the stimuli which is
impinging on to it now the filter theory
explains while there is so little of the
meaning of the unintended message in
Shelley's experiment happened the
meaning from the unintended message was
simply not processed and that is why we
only get the basic physical features of
the unintended you remember says
experiment that we talked a while ago
and as I said from the unintended year
things like the basic property of the
message whether it is in forward or
backward direction or whether it is a
male or a female which is which is
speaking this message these way process
but nothing beyond that and so that is
what the filter theory goes ahead and
says it accommodates that and it says
that these are the only things which can
be processed or which is processed
through this particular theory because
other pictures are not being attained
now the question comes that can be not
here or can we not pay attention to to
message at the same time can we pay
attention to to message at the same time
is it that if we are paying paying
focusing on one message is it that the
other message gets passed on our only
physical basic physical features of the
stimulus a register broadband propose
that two messages that contain very
little information or that information
or if the information is presented very
slowly in this case we can process both
the messages
so what broadband goes ahead and
proposes that there are situations in
which we can focus our attention or even
if you are focusing attention on one
message we can process the other message
and that happens in only those cases
where either both the years contain very
basic minimal information the messages
contain very basic in minimal
information or the presentation rate is
very slow now in these two cases and in
these two cases alone both the years can
be tended to or what the messages can be
actually read or perceived but an
interesting thing was pointed out by
someone called Marie in 1959 and he
stated something called the cocktail
party phenomenon now what is the
cocktail party phenomenon no in the
cocktail party phenomena look at the
figure on your right as you see there's
so many people sitting here and it's a
large party which is happening everybody
is enjoying this large sounds loud music
everywhere and so even in this cases and
you are focusing yourself on to what
your friend next to you is talking so
this person or these people are actually
listening to listening to somebody who
is talking among their growth now in the
cocktail party phenomena what Mireille
suggests is that if your name is said or
if somebody's name is uttered this
message even if we are not attending to
will pass this filter will pass the
filter which
filter he talks about and that raises a
problem now what he says what more he
goes ahead and says in the cocktail
party phenomena is that shadowing
performance is disrupted when one's own
name is embedded in either the
unattended or the attended year now this
happens as important materials can
penetrate the filter set up by setter to
block unintended messages now bachelors
experiments say that only all although
only thirty percent of people could
actually when could actually hear their
name when they were not informed before
but then this really happened which
basically means that there are certain
stimuli out there where which can be
processed when your name is being
processed from the unintended ear which
means that it is being processed not at
the level of the stimuli but the level
of meaning because you know your name
has a meaning and when your name is
being processed when somebody is
speaking your name it is a meaning so at
the neck even at the level of meaning
your name or words like fire or words
which are more important to your
adaptation are process and so what the
cocktail for a party phenomena goes
ahead and says that whatever broadband
suggested in his theory filter theory
which says that only those messages we
are tending to gets passed and processed
from meaning whereas other messages if
ever process a process for basic
properties is actually wrong and so he
demonstrated that through this phenomena
where he where he was very shown that
people's own name or some important
words which are adaptive in nature can
be processed
even from the unintended here so even if
in a big party where you are enjoying
yourself listening very hard to your
friends and somebody calls your name it
is found that most people turn around
and look at who is calling their name
which means that they are able to attend
within that huge voice when that huge
noise into their name and the reasoning
that was provided for this particular
feature of the
cocktail party phenomena was that
attention fluctuates since attention
fluctuates since since the attended year
never takes up 100% of attention that
tension keeps on fluctuation in between
there an Indian and an intended year and
that could be the reason why the
cocktail party phenomena happens so
shadowing in Westham shadowing doesn't
take 100% of attention since attention
fluctuates between the attend agent on a
10-day dr and that could be the reason
why you are able to hear at the message
level the information from the
unattended year now a nitrous pen
actually goes ahead and hits back at or
demonstrates that whatever morris says
in terms of attention fluctuation or not
or the fact that hundred percent
attention is not being paid on to that
in nature ear is wrong and so anna
transmen designed and very ingenious
experiment to test whether the attended
channel the channel the year that is
being used for shadowing that has been
used for reading aloud the words at
which is being put into that year
whether 100 percent attention is being
is devoted to this year and so in her
experiment what she did was she used the
same dichotic listening task in which
two years were there or two the two
different years got two different kind
of messages and what really happened is
that the message one year was to be
shadowed and the other year was not to
be shadowed not in the only interesting
thing or the only new thing in this
experiment was that in the middle of in
the middle of the the whole listening
task the messages very diverse so the
message on the right here went to the
left here and the message from the left
here right i went to the right here what
really happened the results of the
experiment suggest that people who were
paying attention or shadowing the left
ear and as soon as the message from the
left ear shifted to the right here they
continued hearing the message from the
left ear and repeated a couple of words
also of the message from when even even
after the message got reversed into the
right here which means that they were
clearly focusing hundred-person
attendant so at the point when the
switch happened people didn't know the
switch people didn't follow the switch
and they moved or they were able to
repeat a couple of words from the
unintended year or the messages from the
unintended year after the switch it
basically means that people were paying
100% attention into the attended year
and later on as time progressed or after
the couple of seconds people started
repeating after the switch messages from
the unintended year which basically
proves that people are able to to pay
100% attention and that the the the
reasoning that attention fluctuates is
is not so correct a similar experiment
was done by someone called wooden Conan
and so they wanted to test similar
experimentation by wooden Conan and
Conway Conan and bunting in 2001
resulted in showing that messages from
the untreated year was also processed
that's challenging the filter theory and
so what wouldn't Conan's experiment was
that wooden Cornyn use the same dichotic
listening task for their experimentation
now they have they gave on both the
years two different film clips to be
heard on one year you have the grapes of
what dialogue from The Grapes of what
which was being processed and on the
other year from 2000 Space Odyssey
dialogues were from that particular
movie was being
repeated and so people they were to
group of people who were able or who
were given this kind of a task to be
done and a control group was also there
no people were asked to shadow the
grapes of our dialogue for the grapes of
what movie and the words represented 175
words per minute so basically the setup
is like this the the two years here two
different movie dialogues the left
here's something from the The Grapes of
what movie and the right here here's of
dialogues from 2000 Space Odyssey to
group of people do that there is a
control group also the witch which is
there and the word presentation is 175
words Munro words per minute and people
are asked to shadow or repeat aloud the
message which comes on the left ear or
the year which is which is here in the
grapes of what now five minutes into the
experiment five minutes after the
experiment started the unintended year
the year which was here in 2001 Space
Odyssey dialogue there there was a
reversal so the message goes reverse or
black test a back messaging was done so
that words were repeated from front to
back a bachelor doing or a backward
message was played into it and that
happened only for 30 seconds and later
on after that one group heard the or
followed on to the original experiment
for two and a half minute one group
followed the experiment for one and a
half minute and the control group
actually never saw or never heard the
back of messaging into the unintended
year now it was the result what would be
the result of the experiment and so then
experiment like this the result is that
people who notice the backward problem
shadow the people who actually go ahead
and
notice that there is a backward
shadowing on one of the year they they
they create or they do more number of
errors and this error exit actually gets
generated after the backward messaging
stops whereas people who actually do not
people who actually do not hear this
backward messaging they never notice
that the backward messaging was done
also the third group who didn't hear any
kind of backward message they never
heard any any kind of thing and so there
was that was what was comparable and so
the idea from this is that this at this
idea of attention shifting or attention
fluctuating between between two years is
not so correct and that was what was
relate so that was the main idea of
wouldn't condense theory so they went
ahead and this particular experiment
suggests supported the filter theory
that when only those messages you are
tending to actually go ahead and a
process but those messages you are not
attending to are not process that is the
bottom line of the wooden Condon
experiment now these are very
interesting experiments or these are a
very interesting theory of attention but
later on another attentional theory or
theory of attention of how the attention
works or how attention goes attention
filter goes ahead and looks at cognitive
resources or the location of cognitive
resources two different factors are
different cognitive tasks and one of the
limitation of this was proposed by
someone called Anna Treisman so ni
Treisman what she did was the night rise
when 1960 proposed a modified theory of
attention which is called the
attenuation theory it's a very simple
theory to look at now the theory
proposes that messages from the
unintended year is not blocked so what
happens then messages from the
unintended year according to Anna
tradesmen is actually toned down is
brought down or volume down is
attenuated and so what she says
is the volume of the unintended message
that the tone of the unintended message
is attenuated or a brought down and that
is the reason why this kind of an
attentional filter the early works so
incoming messages what an address meant
but then extended arteries to that any
incoming message any incoming
information on to the sense organ before
the the attentional filter works on to
gets cross through attach our three
stage attentional filter and what are
these attentional filters so incoming
messages what she says are subjected to
three kinds of analysis there is a
physical analysis there is an analysis
at the word level and there is an
analysis at the meaning level we quickly
look into that in a minute
now some messaging units are processed
quite easily because they have more
adaptation or more adaptive value right
and sometimes messages are also
processed from the unintended year so
some messages from the unintended year a
process because they have adaptive value
like your name your your words like fire
danger that kind of words because they
have adaptive value there or they help
you negate a threat some of the messages
are also processed from the unintended
year because they are in context for
example if an end ended here you are
being played this message - is chased by
the dog and from the attended year if
you have words like cat into it you will
quickly go ahead and hear the word cat
it is something called the context
effect
so sometimes context in which the
message is being played the context of
the message also helps us in attending
or in processing messages from the
unintended year
so what tradesmen and a tradesmen says
that any message which has been
processed which is new process to the
attentional filter goes through three
stage of filtering three extensive stage
of filtering so I have a drawing here to
basically go ahead and show you that how
does it happen so this is the incoming
message any incoming message and the
first level of analysis are the physical
properties of the sound of in terms of
sound BIC since we are looking at the
dichotic listening task for I but sound
here what happens is the first level of
analysis F is at the level of physical
property and so here physical properties
of the sound or the message which is
being relayed ordinarily to you in terms
of its pitch and loudness is what is
being focused on so this is where the
focus is if messages pass through this
stage it goes through a second level of
analysis where a linguistic or parsing
as syllables and words is done so if the
messages are not filtered at level one
of attention which is the attention
attention filter dependent or based on
the physical property a second level is
our second level analysis the second
level filtering is initiated and in this
level what really happens is that the
filter is dependent on so the linguistic
parsing in terms of words and syllables
and so if in terms of words and
syllables the filter operates here in
terms of the linguistic property of the
world so what kind of linguistic
property a word has or whether it is in
which context how many words are there
the differentiation in terms of da ba
kind of one thing it is it happens at
this level even if at this level the
filtering cannot be done if there is a
problem in filtering or if the filter
doesn't work in this level a third level
of filtering is or level three analysis
is is is run on to a level three filter
is run on to the incoming messages which
is the semantic level and here if the
messages are not blocked or cannot be
blocked at level one or level two a
semantic level filter is applied where
the messages are blocked in terms of the
meaning and so here the filtering
happens in terms of
what the message has or what is the
meaning of the message on the basis of
that basically go ahead and make the the
filtration or the blocking of messages
are done in terms of the filtering and
what an a tradesman goes ahead and says
is that the cocktail party phenomena
happens because your name or certain
other words which are adaptive value
have lower thresholds when they have
lower thresholds they are get processed
from level one level two and level three
and add the level three even at the
levels here the semantic level it is the
meaning of your name and so it since it
has very less threshold it gets
processed
now what Treisman na Treisman goes in
and says is that people will use these
levels of analysis based on at what
level they can separate the attended and
the unattended year so let's say the
messages of similar physical property is
coming at both the years so filtering
will not be done here and so a second
level will be applied where people will
be looked at in both the messages will
be looked at in terms of the linguistic
properties in terms of the words in
terms of the phases that is that suppose
both the messages have the same tone the
same physical property as the say as
well as the same linguistic property
only in those terms only in those cases
a semantic level analysis will be done
now to prove this analyze men did an
experiment a dichotic listening
experiment where both the years were
hearing a message and in both the in in
the attended year the message was was
about a particular seashore and the word
Bank came in some here and on the
unintended year the financial structure
Bank was being produced or something
related to the finance structure was
being put into and so for distinguishing
when Bank the word Bank came in
the years they were having the same
physical properties the same speed the
same word properties for words same kind
of a thing and so a semantic level
analysis a semantic level filter was
applied and because the context in which
the tended message was working on the
bank what they were disclosed being
described in the attended message was in
terms of Ashish or a bank of ash or a
bank of a see kind of a thing
bank of a river kind of a thing the
water body and so that was the message
it was grabbed and the financial
institution which was being grabbed
which was employed on the unintended
year which also had the word bank was
not taken forward and so at this level
the kind of analysis or the kind of
interpretation was done so basically
then these are the theories which have
been proposed for using or for attention
studying attention or how does the
location of attention really works
another theory which is out there which
looks into which adds on to the the
theories that we are discussing is
something called late selection theory
now this theory is much similar to what
the filter theory has in it was proposed
by someone called duration 2h in 1963
and what does this theory and the theory
was of course modified by Norman in 1968
and so what does the theory say well the
theory takes up some information from
the filter theory and some information
from an attachment theory and comes up
with a new theory and what this theory
says is that the filter that Broadman
talks about doesn't happen at the
initial stage of processing of a message
what happens at a later stage at a
meaning stage and that is what the
theory is all about so what this theory
goes ahead and says that all messages
are routinely processed for at least
some aspects of meaning and the
bottleneck the filter since in the in
the filter theory the bottle name or the
filter the filter is equivalent to the
bottleneck think of a bottle and
the neck of the bottle basically
prevents spillage of information so the
bottle neck or the neck of the bottle is
thought of as a filter and so in the
filter theory this bottle neck is
towards the top of the bottle and so
since it is there what happens is much
information doesn't rush in and so the
spillage of information from the inside
to the outside is reduced now what - the
Russia's Russian versus 1963 theory of
late selection says is that this
bottleneck appears at a later phase of
time at a later stage in message
processing and the bottleneck comes in a
later point of time so a message
important depends on many factors
what is what makes a message important
according to this theory so basically
what they say is that most messages are
processed through all the stages to
process through most of the features and
to our end to some level of meaning and
only at the level of the meaning we have
this filter or bottleneck coming in so
if this is how I have the filter theory
where this is the bottleneck and later
on this is the processing stages this is
if I can describe the filter theory the
late selection theory says that this is
how it looks like so all messages are
processed early on and later there is a
filter a bottleneck which ad through the
meaning using the meaning as the reason
for the filter or meaning being the
variable which controls the filter
through which a message is stopped or
block and so what they have again go
ahead and say that there are several
other variables which determine how the
filter will work and they say that the
content and personal significance of
messages are also responsible for this
filter addition what is the content the
message and what is the the the personal
significance of a message for example
names of people for example certain
words which are personally significant
to people they have very less threshold
and they are not blocked by the filter
even at the late stage and for
process for meaning it is led in that
kind of information is letting whether
you are focusing it or not and another
thing that they bring into the picture
another interesting variable that bring
into the picture of attention is
something called the observers level of
alertness how alert somebody is that
defines how you will process an
information or how much information you
will you process the more alert you are
the better processing of messages you
can do the more attention you can pay
the lesser alert you are the lower
alertness you are showing for example
alertness in sleep or if you are in a
sleep stage if you are sleeping you have
very low lower level of alertness and so
the message will not be processed at all
an additional factor is the complexity
of the message if complex messages are
there then these messages will take more
resources and so processing will be
difficult but if easy messages are there
then even the non intended messages
actually get processed so in this
lecture we looked at what is attention
what are the various factors which
determine attention what are the
theories which go ahead and explain
attention we looked at three theories of
attention and try to compare these
theories of course we will do a more
comprehensive comparison of these
methods or these theories at a later
Slater stage or later point of time but
this is what we did in the structure we
looked at what is attention what factors
control attention what is the definition
of it and best of all how do we study
attention it's an interesting thing
because once as I discussed before if I
say don't pay attention you start paying
attention to it so how is it solved an
answer to this is something called the
dichotic listening task so by by we'll
meet again in the next lecture and
continue with this thank you
[Music]
you